el alto consejo francés sobre el clima
ha emitido una severa advertencia el
despliegue de la tecnología 5g conducirá
a un aumento significativo de la energía
y de las emisiones de gases de efecto
invernadero
la futura huella de carbono de esta red
móvil ya no puede ignorarse la selva
la quinta generación sólo empeorará
nuestros problemas ambientales si no
implementamos medidas adicionales para
regularla en un nuevo y contundente
informe el ente explica que la
tecnología en sí es sólo la punta del
iceberg ya que las emisiones extra de
co2 provendrán sobre todo de los centros
de datos y la fabricación de nuevos
dispositivos electrónicos
por ello los activistas que han luchado
durante mucho tiempo contra estos
servicios esperan que esta evaluación
apoye su causa solicitamos una moratoria
en nuestra petición es aún más relevante
hoy ahora que el consejo ha dicho que
debemos evaluar el impacto ambiental de
la tecnología antes de aplicarla sin
embargo los proveedores de redes
telefónicas defienden que esta vez el
informe ha resaltado aspectos positivos
que hacen que el 5 g sea más eficiente
que sus predecesores anteriores creo con
dichos críticos el primer ordenador que
tú
en 1989 usaba 500 vatios de potencia
mi teléfono inteligente es hoy 1000
veces más potente y solo usa 8 vatios lo
mismo pasa con las redes telefónicas la
última tecnología es más eficiente al
culpable o motril al respecto del
presidente de manuel macrón quien creó
el consejo ha prometido transparencia a
la par que ha insistido que francia se
está quedando atrás de sus vecinos
europeos
a fines de 2025 dos tercios del país
estarán cubiertos por el 5g